the helicopter that brought Barack Obama
to Pretoria flew above the hospital
where doctors are treating Nelson
Mandela the US president said he
wouldn't visit the anti-apartheid leader
but he did meet privately with members
of Mandela's family Obama also met South
Africa's current President Jacob Zuma
their talks focused on economic
relations but inevitably came back to
Mandela who South Africans know as
Madiba Madiba's moral courage this
country's historic transition to a free
and democratic nation has been a
personal inspiration to me it has been
an inspiration to the world and it
continues to be later Obama returned to
Johannesburg where he met with students
in Soweto to talk about their continents
economic and political future there is
as the song says a new Africa more
prosperous more confident taking its
place on the world stage the audience
welcomed Obama's indications that he
plans to boost trade between the u.s.
and Africa but many are worried about
South Africa's future without Mandela
supporters continue to gather outside of
the hospital of the man considered to be
the father of their nation